the city of a thousand planets is under
attack
ages valaria none lauralee and find the
threat and eliminated head sounds pretty
grim when you put it like that
hmm bingo
run
humans are house so predictable clearly
you've never met a woman
hilarious lady pg-13 a long time ago
when I was 10 years old I discovered the
first album of this comic book Elena and
I was like oh my god what is this thing
I think what's like me is the
storytelling it was the first time that
we see the modern couple they were
acting like two normal people today
except that they are in the 28th century
and everything is weird
[Music]
the environment was just crazy it's like
aliens everywhere and world's everywhere
when I was working on the Fifth Element
with Miss year main designer from Berlin
he was the one saying why don't do
vinayan why do you do this Fifth Element
thing I mean the technology was not good
at the time it was not possible and as
way later avatar arrived and avatar
makes everything possible there is no
limit anymore man
I do the sorry we should use now four
years ago did you ever think you would
get turned into a movie
no I started to work with the artists
three years before on the phone you
start the storyboard a year and a half
before we were so proud when I'm stunned
to found that the shooting almost looks
easy
we have valerian and Laura lein there
are two cops show your gun and you're a
good job boy and they can travel in
space and time mullerian is little
pretentious there Becca I prefer how
about we went for backup
for a change he always theater he will
save the day everything is a little too
easy friend Laura lein is probably my
first love 10 years old you know you
start to get feeling shaken and I feel a
lot better
nice to see you a lot largely splendid
as ever
they are very un big fight and is
desperately in love with her I jumped
off a quest a lot more sense
their mission bring them to Space
Station met about a thousand alien
species from the four corners of the
universe
welcome to alpha alpha called the city
of thousand planets because all the
knowledge in the universe
is there the Alpha station has 3236
species with over 5000 languages spoken
it's Wall Street GT of science United
Nations brought away
everything is there so it makes the city
the most important in the entire
university it's paradise
it has always been my dream stupid that
character is a big screen and now it's
the time on the fifth element there is
188 patrol effect shots when in Valyrian
there's 2734 I've waited my entire life
to make this film and the journey has
been amazing I gave it everything I had
and I cannot wait to share it with you
so have fun see you inside
you
[Music]
you